mes chers compatriotes de l'hexagone
d'outre-mer et de l'étranger le monde
dans lequel nous vivons et menaçant la
guerre en ukraine nous le rappelle
terriblement parmi ces menaces il ya ce
risque immense celui que l'histoire du
monde s'écrivent sans la france je veux
que nous ayons le courage de retrouver
la maîtrise de notre destin celui d'une
france forte et s'ouvrait après ce
quinquennat des renoncements je vous
propose de reconstruire notre pays le
préalable c'est de restaurer l'autorité
l'autorité c'est ne plus accepter aucune
zone de non droit où règne la loi des
caïds celle des prêcheurs de haine je ne
veux pas que nos enfants vivent dans une
société apeurés ont éclaté
communautariser l'autorité s'est donnée
à nos forces de l'ordre et à notre
justice les moyens pour appliquer
l'impunité zéro la peur doit changer de
camp avec une justice qui condamne
rapidement et fermement l'autorité
consiste aussi à faire respecter nos
frontières et stopper l'immigration
incontrôlée grâce à l'instauration de
quotas migratoires
l'école de la république doit redevenir
la fabrique de la france celle du mérite
et de l'égalité des chances pour relever
notre pays il faut aussi un grand vent
de liberté je veux que le travail paye
plus que l'assistanat et qu'il soit payé
à sa juste valeur j'augmenterais les
salaires nets de 10% d'ici la fin du
mandat je suis la vraie candidate du
pouvoir d'achat je me battrai pour la
liberté d'entreprendre sans être accablé
d'impôt est liberté d'innover sans être
entravé de procédure
il je veux que chaque français et la
liberté de fonder une famille et de
devenir propriétaire que chacun ait la
liberté de transmettre le fruit d'une
vie de travail comme nous devons avoir
le souci de transmettre notre patrimoine
naturel culturel à nos enfants pour
libérer les français il faut avoir le
courage de réformer de débureaucratiser
de décentraliser nous héritons 2000
milliards de dette non plus maintenant
il faut dépenser mieux et moi parce que
cette dette ce sont des impôts différés
parce que l'argent magique ça n'existe
pas c'est votre argent pour rassembler
les français il faut aussi les respecter
respecter leur dignité vous devez
pouvoir être soigné partout sur le
territoire sans délai grâce à des
milliers de médecins que nous en verrons
dans les communes au milan demain vous
devez pouvoir vivre dignement de votre
retraite les retraités ont été les
grands sacrifiés de ce quinquennat avec
la hausse de la csg et la désindexation
des pensions avec moi les retraites
seront indexés automatiquement sur
l'inflation est plus aucun français qui
aura travaillé toute sa vie
nora une retraite inférieure au smic
et puis respecter les français c'est
tendre la main aux plus fragiles et les
aider à se relever c'est accompagnés
chacun dans les accidents de la vie et
je pense en particulier à nos
compatriotes en situation de handicap
que si une femme d'ordre et de concorde
je vous promets de réconcilier et de
rassembler tous les français quelles que
soient leur origine leur croyance leur
lieu de vie car avec moi chacune et
chacun aura droit ou nous-mêmes respect
et puis je veux redonner espoir à notre
jeunesse cette jeunesse audacieuse
généreuse qui fait la richesse de notre
nation nos projets et celui des
générations futures car jaune le
reléguerait ni dette écologique ni
dettes financières abyssales je leur
fait ce serment j'aurai le courage de
faire ce qu'il faut pour reconstruire la
france que nous aimons vive la
république et vive la france
[Musique]